-We are now on day 4
of the biggest scandal
in politics,
one of the biggest stories,
arguably, of all time,
a mystery for the ages
that has befuddled experts,
rocked the world,
and which scientists
and historians
will ponder for decades --
what happened to Nicki Minaj's
cousin's friend's balls?
[ Laughter ]
For more on this --
and let me know,
this is the first time
I've regretted
calling the segment this --
it's time for "A Closer Look."
Ugh!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
As you've probably gathered,
from 18 months of pandemic life,
there are lots
of weird medical opinions
floating around out there.
It seems like
everybody's got one.
A new virus breaks out
and, suddenly, everyone turns
into an apothecary
from the 16th century.
"I tested positive for COVID.
Just take some ginger root
and elderflower,
and you'll be fine.
You know how much
apple cider vinegar
I've been drinking?
The good news
is I haven't gotten COVID.
The bad news is
all my teeth are gone."
[ Laughter ]
We got to show me the pictures
before the "Closer Looks."
[ Laughter ]
I'm not just supposed
to roll through that.
[ Laughter continues ]
These are prosthetic teeth.
Props to the "SNL"
props department.
[ Laughter ]
Of course, we just went
through four years
of a presidency led
by a notorious scam artist
with all kinds of insane
medical opinions,
so much so, that the current
president, Joe Biden,
reasonably felt he had
to debunk one
of the most infamous examples,
while talking
about climate change.
-We know what the driver is --
climate change.
We know what's causing
climate change --
human activity.
This is no longer subject
to debate.
And I might add,
windmills do not cause cancer.
-I like imagining the one guy
who hadn't heard
Trump's original comments
about windmills causing cancer
try to figure out what the hell
Biden's talking about.
I mean, without the context,
it makes no sense.
It's like seeing
a surgeon general's warning
on a pack of cigarettes
that says...
Has that been a problem?
[ Laughter ]
Just talking about real things
Donald Trump said or did
makes you sound
like an insane person,
like you're describing
hallucinations
to a psychiatrist.
I saw a man on my television.
"And what did this man say?"
He said, "Canadians
are smuggling shoes
across the border.
"And what else did he say?"
He said Paris
is no longer Paris.
"I see.
Have you been drinking vinegar?"
It's such a weird legacy
of our politics
that presidents,
for the rest of our lifetimes,
will just have to toss out
non sequiturs like that
because of Trump.
One day, President
Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson
will be giving a speech
on manufacturing.
Out of nowhere, he'll have
to say something like,
"Also, you guys,
don't drink bleach."
So, Biden debunked the cancer
part of Trump's comments,
but, you know, I also wish
he would've said something
about the sound effects.
-And they say the noise
causes cancer.
You tell me that one, okay.
"Rirr, rirr!"
[ Laughter ]
Why didn't Biden
have anything to say
about the noise Donald Trump
thinks windmills make?
[ As Biden ]
That's not what a windmill
sounds like,
alright, Jack?
Listen up, folks.
I'm serious.
I'm not joking around here.
It's not, "Rawrr, rawrr!"
It's more like,
"Whoosh! Whoosh!"
[ Laughter ]
Or, you know, it's,
"Womp! Womp!"
Get it right, pal.
[ Laughter ]
So, Biden felt the need
to remind everyone
that windmills do not,
in fact, cause cancer,
and, now, the White House has
to address yet another bit
of misinformation that has
circulated on the Internet.
You may have heard about it --
the sad case of Nicki Minaj's
cousin's friend's balls,
which, by the way, is the worst
of the Hardy Boys Mysteries.
[ Laughter ]
As I'm sure you'll recall,
Minaj tweeted...
Two governments have now had
to correct this information,
and we will get to that,
but let's not let off the hook
this woman
who called off a wedding
because her fiancé's balls
swelled up.
The only way
I'd ever accept that is
if it happened during the vows.
In sickness and in health...
"In sickness and in...
Honey, what's happening
to your balls?"
"Uhh, it's nothing.
[ Laughter ]
Just say, 'I do.'"
"No, I'm out.
I don't like this! I'm out!"
[ Laughter ]
Now, I know a lot --
a lot -- has already been said
about this tweet,
but here's my question...
If it gives you big balls,
how come this is the first
we're hearing of it?
[ Laughter ]
Nobody's shy about their
big balls.
Literally,
it means you're not shy.
If the vaccine gave you
huge balls,
CVS would be jammed
with college kids
getting their eighth
and ninth booster shots.
How come we haven't seen
an epidemic
of men waddling around
with their legs out
and swinging their nuts forward
before they sit down?
I mean, I got vaccinated
and, if swollen balls
were a side effect,
you would see it every time
I got up to greet a guest
and had to sit back down.
You know, because I'd have to do
like a swinging motion,
like I'd have to like
do one of these,
[ Laughter ]
you know, lest I sit on them
and make a horrific noise,
like...
-"Rirr! Rirr!"
[ Laughter ]
I don't think that's
the noise I make.
You know that classic thing
when you sit on your balls --
"Rawrr! Rawrr!"
[ Laughter ]
Another bizarre consequence
of this episode
is that it's brought us
the spectacle
of news anchors having
to repeat the claims
and sometimes say
the words themselves on air.
-The singer told fans
that the COVID-19 vaccine
impacts reproductive health.
That's not exactly
how she phrased it.
-She tweeted that her
cousin's friend
got the vaccine and became
impotent
after his reproductive organs
swelled up.
-She said he has swollen
testicles.
-"His testicles became swollen."
-"His testicles became
swollen."
-"His testicles became swollen."
-"His testicles became
swollen."
-Swollen testicles.
-Swollen
testicles.
-Swollen genitals.
-Swelling to his genitals.
-Cousin's Swollen Friend's
Testicle Gate.
-Nothing worse
than hearing news anchors
say the words
"swollen testicles."
It's like hearing your grandpa
say the words
aroused or engorged.
[ Laughter ]
These moments are when I miss
having Tom Brokaw around
to deliver the news.
That's the only voice I want
to hear say those words.
[ As Brokaw ]
Breaking news.
Gerald Ford fell down the
stairs on Air Force One
[ Laughter ]
and, now, he has
swollen testicles.
[ Laughter ]
Richard Nixon engorged
at the news.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, we're now in day 4
of this scrandal --
scrotal scandal --
[ Laughter ]
and we've gotten to the point
where the White House
is getting involved.
-The White House says
it offered Nicki Minaj
a phone call to answer
her questions
about the safety
of COVID vaccines.
It comes after Minaj tweeted
earlier this week
and unverified story
about her cousin's friend
in Trinidad,
who got the vaccine and became
"impotent."
Yesterday, Minaj tweeted
that she had been invited
to the White House.
That prompted the White House
to issue clarification,
saying the invitation was
for a phone call,
not an in-person visit.
-Administration officials
tell CNN's Jeff Zeleny,
"As we have with others,
we offered a call
with Nicki Minaj
and one of our doctors
to answer questions
that she has about safety,
the safety and effectiveness
of the vaccine."
-What a bummer for that
White House doctor.
He gets the best news --
that he's going to meet
Nicki Minaj! --
followed by the worst news --
the reason why.
"Hello. Why, yes, I would love
to meet Miss Minaj!
Well, I'm a huge fan.
What's it for?
Uh-huh.
Yes.
Testicles?
[ Laughter ]
Swollen, you say?
And they were just weeks away
from their wedding?
Well, do you think if
she called it off for that,
they were ever really in love?"
[ Laughter ]
Second question -- can we get
Fauci to take this one?
Any interest, Fauci?
Ohh!
The face slap is back.
We found out about the
White House outreach to Minaj
after she had originally
tweeted that...
And you know what?
I think they should do it.
I think they should meet
at the White House
and I think they should invite
Minaj's cousin's friend as well.
I mean, why not?
Rudy Giuliani's been there
and he is a swollen testicle.
He looks like the cartoon
they show in a sex ed video.
"See what happened?
He forgot to swing forward."
[ Laughter ]
And I think we already
have an idea how Fauci
would handle such a conversation
because he was asked about this
scandal on national television
and he actually had
to tell people,
"No, the vaccine will not
make your balls swell up."
-I wouldn't normally even
ask you about this,
but Nicki Minaj has nearly
180 million followers
on Twitter and Instagram,
combined.
She's beloved by her fans.
She's a huge talent, obviously.
Her tweet was seized upon
by vaccine opponents
as some sort of evidence.
I want you to address
what she said
because, for anyone out there
who has any questions
about this,
Dr. Fauci, is there any evidence
that the Pfizer, the Moderna,
or the J&J vaccines
cause any reproductive issues,
in men or women?
-The answer to that, Jake,
is a resounding no.
There's no evidence
that it happens,
nor is there
any mechanistic reason
to imagine that it would happen.
So the answer to your
question is no.
-Poor Fauci. When this
whole thing first started,
he was a national hero
celebrated by all,
played by Brad Pitt on "SNL."
Now, 18 months in,
he's answering questions
about whether the vaccines turn
your balls into cantaloupes.
We've gotten so insane,
as a nation,
we've turned our most celebrated
infectious disease expert
into an exasperated
high school sex ed teacher.
"I heard you can't get pregnant
in a Jacuzzi."
"Well, I heard
you don't need a condom,
as long as you stand up
right after you're done."
[ As Fauci ]
Guys, come on.
None of that's true.
Do I really need to show you
the movie again?
Any day, now, I feel like
the Brooklyn version of Fauci
is going to come out
and he's just going to snap.
[ As Fauci ]
Hey, the vaccine doesn't
give you a big balls.
You know what gives you
big balls?
Walking around Coney Island
after midnight,
looking for the kid
who stole your switchblade.
Ohhh, I got big balls.
[ Laughter ]
I got big balls,
and enough hair around them
to make Rudy Giuliani
another toupee.
I'm Fauci!
[ Laughter ]
Also, I like
that Jake Tapper
prefaced the question with,
"I wouldn't normally
ask you this,"
as if, if he didn't,
Fauci would've said --
[ As Fauci ]
"Whoa, whoa, whoa,
what is this, Tapper,
the [Bleep] Ball Question Hour?
[ Laughter ]
And Fauci is not the only
medical professional
who's had to waste his time
on this nonsense.
Yesterday, the health minister
in Trinidad & Tobago
officially debunked any reports
of swollen testicles
as a vaccine side effect
in a formal press conference.
-One of the reasons we could
not respond yesterday,
in real time, to Miss Minaj
is that we had to check
[ Laughing ] and make sure
that what she was claiming
was either true or false.
We did and, unfortunately,
we wasted so much time
yesterday,
runnin' down this false claim.
It is, as far as we know,
at this point in time,
there has been no such reported
either side effect
or adverse event.
And what was sad about this
is that it wasted
our time yesterday.
As we stand now,
there is absolutely no reported
such side effect
or adverse event
of testicular swelling
in Trinidad or, I daresay,
Dr. Hinds, anywhere else?
-None that we know of.
-None that we know of
anywhere else in the world.
-He sounds annoyed.
Or should I say, testy.
[ Laughter ]
That's the kind of jokes you get
when Samberg's in the house.
[ Laughter ]
Should've put a mic
in his dressing room.
[ Laughter ]
You really got to feel
for doctors and scientists.
They're desperately trying
to beat back a pandemic
that's raging on,
despite their best efforts,
and they keep getting
dumber and dumber questions.
First, it was the president,
talking about ingesting bleach.
Then, it was
the demon sperm lady,
talking
about hydroxychloroquine.
Then, horse paste.
Now, swollen testicles.
What's next?
"Okay, Doc hear me out.
They say horse paste
cures COVID,
but my horse has giant balls.
So does that mean
all COVID cures
give you a giant horse balls?
And, before you answer that,
I'm not asking for myself.
I'm asking for my horse.
Hold on.
I have to sneeze.
[ Equine snort ]
Okay, I'm also asking
for myself.
[ Laughter ]
The evidence about just
how incredibly safe
and effective these vaccines are
is out there
and it's been out there
for a long time.
Moreover, getting vaccinated,
which could save your life,
isn't just
about your own health.
It's about protecting those
around you.
That's why vaccine
misinformation can be
so dangerous.
And, as for Nicki Minaj's
cousin's friend,
I just hope someone finds
this poor man and helps him.
And you can probably tell
it's him
from the sound his pants make
when he walks.
-"Rirr! Rirr!"
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.